[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to my tomes of
terror book review series
so scott smith he's an author i've
talked about on this series before
he's only published
a couple of novels during his writing
career he also writes screenplays
luckily for him though uh both of the
ones that he's written are pretty
[ __ ] rad
so if you remember i read and reviewed
his 2006 novel the ruins not too long
ago uh he also wrote the screenplay for
the movie for that which came out in
2008 when which is actually like quite
decent
but as it happened i had never read his
debut novel
the 1993 sort of noir thriller a simple
plan and look i actually have
the book this time i know like for a
long time i've been reading like uh
ebooks like on my kindle unlimited so i
haven't like had a print book but look i
actually have a print book this time so
there's that
now i did see because um probably most
people know that in 1998 uh sam raimi
directed a movie adaptation of this and
i had seen that movie and i remember
liking it very much but it had been so
long since i'd seen it that i had
completely forgotten like most of the
plot points so i was just kind of like
well i'll just go into the book and you
know i don't really remember all that
it's about i just kind of like
remembered the setup and that was it i
didn't remember all the twists and turns
so i was like so it won't be spoiled for
me um so i got the idea to read the book
actually because mostly because of uh
jordaline reads who is one of my
favorite uh booktubers as they call it
like she reviews books mostly horror but
she does kind of other stuff as well
and she [ __ ] loves this book and i
was like you know i really liked that
movie and i bet the book is pretty good
too um because the ruins was also
fantastic so i said i'm just gonna bite
the bullet and i'm gonna buy a copy and
i'm gonna read that [ __ ] and
holy [ __ ]
i mean
if this book is not
one of the most
like tense
nail-biting
and really like relentlessly grim things
that i've ever read
then i don't know what the [ __ ] anything
is anymore you know what i'm saying it's
excellent i mean i think this book i
liked the ruins a lot but i think i like
this one better i mean this is like just
a smashing smashing book um and this is
one of those books that i don't think
i've been like this compelled to like
finish something for a really really
long time i mean some books it's just
kind of like oh i get really into them
and stuff like that but this one i was
just kind of like i have to like keep
reading because i have to see like what
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] is happening next
now if you've seen the 1998 movie
which um has a great [ __ ] cast by the
way bill paxton is in it billy bob
thornton is in it and uh bridget fonda
know that the movie sticks pretty close
to the book like um at least up until
the end now scott smith also wrote the
screenplay for the movie as well now so
the end of this
i will say that like some of the things
that happen are kind of the same at the
end
but maybe like some of the motivations
or some of the characters are kind of
like switched around a little bit it's
essentially the same story but i kind of
like that scott smith when he was
writing the screenplay you know stuck
very close to the novel until the end
and he's like well you know if you read
the book i don't really necessarily want
to do like a slavish adaptation i'm
going to introduce like a little bit of
variation in it that doesn't really
affect the theme of the story that much
i think the movie they did
soften it up a little bit not that much
um but like i said this book is like
pretty [ __ ]
bleak uh i will say to you that for
whatever reason
i guess just because of like where they
could afford to shoot it or whatever uh
the book actually takes place in ohio
and the movie i think takes place in
minnesota but like i said it doesn't
really like make any difference to the
story so i'm assuming they just did that
for budgetary reasons or whatever like
wherever they were gonna shoot it
so what we have here the story is told
from the first person perspective
of a guy named hank mitchell
and he's an accountant he's like 30 or
in his early 30s
he has a wife named sarah who is a
librarian and she's also eight months
pregnant like at the beginning of the
book
now the couple aren't
wealthy and they're not even really like
upper middle class or anything like that
but they do both have college degrees
they both have stable jobs they have
like a pretty good handle on their
finances they have like quite a bit of
money in savings and they have like kind
of a nice sort of starter home like in a
decent suburb now it turns out that they
kind of ended up back in this small town
ohio where
where hank was from originally due to
kind of unforeseen circumstances or like
money issues and something like that it
wasn't really what they wanted like they
didn't really want to come back here but
they figure oh we'll come back here have
a starter home save up some more money
in a couple of years and then we'll be
able to kind of i mean they're pretty
confident that they'll be able to move
up to something bigger and better like
move to an actual city like one of these
days or something like that so they see
this is like a temporary setback i guess
now hank also has an older brother i
believe he's four years older
whose name is jacob
and jacob is pretty much exactly the
opposite of hank he's very obese he's
very unkempt
uh he's unemployed and doesn't really
seem to be looking for a job or anything
he's not stupid
um i think in the movie if i remember
correct it's been a while since i've
seen the movie but i think billy bob
thornton plays that character and i
think he plays him as like a little bit
mentally challenged he's absolutely not
in the in the book in the book he's
intelligent he's just kind of like
i don't know he's kind of like sort of
like a big slob who doesn't really have
any ambition in life
mainly his big ambition is like
going hunting and like hanging out with
his friend lou and they you know they
just drink together and lou is a little
bit of like a low life as well like
they're kind of p's in a pod
now hank and jacob the mitchell brothers
they're not exactly estranged
but they really don't have all that much
in common so they don't really like talk
that much even though now they live in
the same town
now two years prior to the events of the
novel hank and jacob's parents
were killed in this really horrific car
crash essentially
they drove like the wrong way like up an
exit ramp and ended up getting hit head
on by a semi
uh so yeah they're super dead
now for a long time like hank had always
thought this was an accident like oh
maybe they had drunk too much and
weren't really paying attention but it
kind of comes to light later on that
it's possible
that it might have been like they might
have done it on purpose like it might
have been suicide and that might have
been brought on by the fact that the
parents were in like a huge amount of
debt and were going to lose their farm
and indeed they did end up like after
they died like the farm ended up having
to be sold and the the house that they
grew up in like that the kids grew up in
like was raised to the ground and you
know the land was sold even though hank
was never really all that close to his
parents because like i said he was kind
of like i don't want to be a farmer i
don't want to live in this small town my
whole life so he like went off to
college and then ended up having to come
back but he wanted to get the [ __ ] out
of there as quickly as possible but he
did kind of vow to uphold this one sort
of peculiar i guess it's not that
peculiar but a little bit of a peculiar
like condition that was in his dad's
will
that condition being once a year at
least once a year i want my two sons
hank and jacob to come together
to the cemetery and visit you know the
parents graves so at the beginning of
the novel it's new year's eve and hank
and jacob are on the way to the cemetery
to do this thing that they have started
you know it's going to be like a yearly
tradition
now lou the lowlife friend of jacob is
also with them because you know they
because jacob and lou were like hanging
out and they're like okay well your
house is on the way to the cemetery so
we'll drop you off on the way
also along for the ride is
mary beth now mary beth is a male dog uh
who belongs to jacob they explain why he
named the dog the male dog mary beth
like later on sort of but yeah it
doesn't really matter all that much
now this dog
actually ends up being essentially
the first link in this chain
of
just steadily escalating
chaos
that will sort of like eventually
doom
the brothers
and many many people that are associated
with them so while they're on their way
to the cemetery along a sort of snowy
road because it's winter and it's ohio
so everything's like covered with snow
so along this road near a nature
preserve
a fox sort of like darts out in front of
the truck
so whoever's driving i can't remember
who was driving but they had to like hit
the brakes really hard to avoid hitting
the fox
now the dog mary beth
sees the fox and is like woohoo and like
jumps out of the truck and like runs
into the nature preserve after the fox
so then the three guys are just kind of
like well [ __ ] me now we have to go and
like get the dog out of the woods
because they can hear the dog like
barking like out in the woods and we
can't leave her leave him rather
like i said i kept wanting to say like
her because the dog's name is mary beth
but yeah
so while they're looking for the dog
they find they're
lying in the snow
is the wreckage of a small airplane
now they're kind of like well we should
probably like call the police and report
this because we're sure pretty sure
somebody's dead in there you know that's
usually what happens
and the two guys like jacob and lou
who are like i said they're kind of like
best friends and they're sort of like
unemployed drunky buddies
and they think that hank is
you know he's kind of like you know
college boy oh you think you're better
than us blah blah blah
so they're always kind of like
conspiring and like making fun of him
and like
you know kind of essentially saying that
he's like soft because he's like a city
boy and all this other kind of stuff so
it's that kind of whole dynamic
so they're basically like well we think
that you should uh go inside like poke
around inside the plane and see what the
[ __ ] is going on in there and he's like
i don't really see why i should need to
do that and they're like no you totally
should
so pretty much because he doesn't want
them like picking on him anymore about
like being a weenie uh he decides to
start poke around instead of poking
around inside this plane
while he's in there not only does he
find uh the dead pilot uh whose eyes
have been pecked out by crows quite
gruesomely
but he also finds a duffel bag
containing 4.4
million dollars now at first
uh hank who is you know quite
responsible you know he's just like a
regular guy he's got a mortgage and he's
got a job and everything like that he's
like look we have to do the right thing
and turn the money into the authorities
nobody just loses 4.4 million dollars
obviously somebody's looking for this
and it's too dangerous for us to keep it
no matter where it came from it's like
it could be from a drug deal and the
criminals will come looking for us it
could be any number of things it's like
we just shouldn't keep it because it's
too dangerous
now jacob and lou though neither of whom
have jobs and lou who has like
substantial gambling debts
are all in favor of keeping the money
now hank at first is like trying to
argue with them and like trying to stand
his ground about it but really
as it goes on he sort of feels his
conviction wavering at the thought of
all that money
and it doesn't really take too much more
argument before he agrees okay we will
keep the cash
but
i have a few conditions
that hopefully will ensure
that we don't get caught for essentially
stealing whoever's money this is like i
said they don't have any idea so first
he tells jacob and lou
i'm gonna hang on to the money myself uh
he's like i'm the most stable and he
correctly points out that jacob and lou
are both drunks uh and are way more
desperate for money than he is he's not
rich like i said but he's doing okay
um so he's like because i'm not as
desperate as you guys i'd be less likely
to like dip into it or to do something
dumb
hank says i'll hide it for the time
being
he also insists we're not gonna tell
anybody about this cash jacob is single
and doesn't have anybody to tell but lou
has a girlfriend that he lives with
named nancy now hank promises that he
won't even tell his own wife sarah about
it which
spoiler alert that promised that he
breaks almost immediately like as soon
as he gets home but that's neither here
nor there
second his second condition
no one is to touch or spend a single
[ __ ] dime of this money
for six months or at least until after
the spring thaw be when the plane is
eventually found because they said as
soon as there's a thaw someone's gonna
find it because it's not like it's super
hidden or anything it's pretty much out
in the open like on this nature preserve
if the plane is found and nobody they
don't hear anybody talking about any
missing money or anything like that he's
like we can assume the money is safe
because no one's looking for it and then
we can divide it up
his third condition
once the money is divided up
everybody has to quietly and separately
leave town and not tell anybody where
they're going
now
this is the simple plan that they have
all agreed to and they do all agree to
this because hank's basically like if
you don't agree to these conditions then
i'm either gonna call the cops right now
and turn the money in or i'm gonna take
it and i'm gonna [ __ ] burn it so you
know what i mean so they're basically
like okay fine we'll we'll do that he's
like all you got to do is wait six
months and if nothing you know if nobody
comes looking for the money then it's
it's free and clear and we'll divide it
up and then we don't have to see each
other anymore
so had everybody adhered to these
simple rules maybe none of the epic
cluster [ __ ] that happens after this
would have happened
but
it's a shame obviously that's not how
the [ __ ] goes
uh because
humans are as we all know imperfect
creatures
and in the case of the characters in
this particular novel they're also
greedy uh
reckless careless
sometimes stupid
and in the end
downright
evil
turns out
that 4 million bucks
is
quite sufficient
to transform
even the most normal of all people into
a complete
psychopath
and boy howdy
does that happen here in [ __ ]
spades
the thing about it though is that
because of scott smith's
prose which is very
it's not it's i don't want to say it's
like unadorned it it is actually quite
atmospheric but it's very gripping it's
very visceral and his pacing is very
very tightly controlled so everything is
just like this slow drip of like
steadily ratcheting like shittery and
you're just kind of like oh [ __ ] like
how much worse can this just keeps
getting worse and worse and worse and
it's just it's [ __ ] crazy
so every step of this descent into utter
madness that ensues is completely
believable and sometimes it even seems
as though
it's inevitable and that's kind of
something that he goes into because this
is all told from like hank's perspective
like his first person point of view so
you know what he's thinking
and it's almost kind of he makes it seem
as though every single link in the chain
everything that happened and like you
know kind of pushed him to all of these
things that he got pushed to
were almost like out of his control or
inevitable like faded so that kind of
goes into like a lot of the you know
there's a lot of that kind of stuff
going on as well
now and it's interesting too because
because everything is from hank's point
of view
who when at the start is just like a
regular family man he's got a wife he's
got a kid on the way he's got a job he
just seems like a nice dude everybody
likes him he's no different from
anybody else that you know
so because of that like the story gets
more and more horrifying as it goes on
because the guy
is able to pretty much justify
every
new
atrocity that he goes to
by essentially portraying himself as a
victim of circumstance like well this
happened which wasn't my fault so that
pushed me into
this thing that i had to do so i didn't
have a choice you know what i mean like
it's almost kind of like well everything
conspired to like take away his freedom
of action so
and you almost kind of like buy it for a
while because in a way the reader like
when you're reading it you you almost
become like complicit in this sort of
like ratcheting savagery because
up to a point like after the point of no
return you're kind of low-key rooting
for hank to like sort of do whatever he
needs to do to like keep the money like
you're almost kind of like disappointed
like with bad chef like oh no he's not
going to get to keep the 4 billion
dollars now and then you're kind of like
realizing holy [ __ ] i'm like complicit
in this because he's obviously doing
like more and more like monstrous things
and not just him like some of the other
ones do it too but it's mostly like him
doing this stuff
so that's kind of like the genius of
this book and it really makes you think
because even you think like you as a
reader
what what if i was in this situation
like what if i found a plane or what if
i found like four million bucks just
like laying around and we didn't really
know who it was from and everything like
that you know you can say all day long
well i wouldn't have made the choices
that the characters in this book made
but i'm assuming that uh most of you out
there have not found just four million
dollars just like laying around in the
snow like right for the taking i
certainly haven't so i think until
you're in that situation
uh with circumstances being what they
are i don't think that you can actually
predict like what you would do and i
think that's what's really fascinating
about this is that
hank the character who is a you know
perfectly likable like i said a very
normal just generic kind of dude uh at
the beginning and
by the end of this book he is
essentially
a monster
but he can
justify every single step like like it
was beyond his control
and it's just it's really scary because
it's almost kind of like
you know it's almost kind of like a
character study
of you know what what hannah aaron
called the banality of evil you know
what i mean where it's just this
step-by-step progression of how just
like a regular joe can end up becoming a
monster and he just excuses every single
thing that he does as being beyond his
control i was pushed into this
circumstance pushed me into this i had
to do it for the outcome that i wanted
like
he almost kind of says that you know he
didn't have a choice at certain points
like once everything had gone and like i
said he kind of like goes back over it
in his head sometimes like literally
like saying well because this happened i
had to do this and because of that i had
to do this and then you just see every
single link in the chain and he almost
like still thinks of himself as a good
person
even
as the murders start to like rack up you
know what i mean so it's really
terrifying like it's a terrifying like
psychological study of how that could
happen and it's completely
and totally believable like i said yeah
maybe some of the choices that he made
and some of the other characters that
made were dumb but that's kind of the
point is like that characters would make
dumb choices if you had like four
million dollars it was just laying there
and you were just kind of like i mean
most people would probably be tempted
you know to do like terrible things to
keep hold of it and scott smith knows
that apparently and is kind of like
using that to sort of like you know
terrify you like that
so
yeah it's just this book is just
stunningly stunningly bleak so i have to
say
uh if you're real into like
thrillers that are just like super grim
and like black-hearted this is a really
good one it'll have you like glued to
the edge of your seat the entire time
and it's just like this really
horrific
kind of
deep dive into the psychology
of someone going from normalcy to like
complete depravity and having a reason
for doing every single thing like just
as it gets as his actions get worse and
worse
so i mean if you're into thrillers at
all you really really have to read this
it's one of the best thrillers that i've
ever read in my whole entire life i mean
it just kind of like i was just like at
the edge of my seat like i said the
whole entire time i was like holy [ __ ]
like how much worse can this get because
you know you know that like bad shit's
gonna happen you know that like people
are gonna get killed and it's just like
terrifying like how bad this [ __ ] gets
and the fact that it's from the guy's
point of view who's doing most of the
bad [ __ ] and his thought processes is
just like chilling but yeah i mean i was
really really into this uh the movie's
good too but like i said if you've seen
the movie and but it was a long time ago
and you don't really remember exactly
what happened the movie is very very
similar at least up until the end but i
mean if you've seen the movie maybe wait
a little while
like before you read the book until you
kind of like forget some of the plot
points because i think it's better
not knowing like all the twists and
turns of the plot and like no because
like i said you know that everything's
gonna go to [ __ ] you know it's gonna get
bad because that's what would happen
like if
if men with this dynamic of people with
this dynamic found four million dollars
and had like all these conditions you
know that shit's gonna go sideways and
it absolutely does but yeah this was a
great [ __ ] tense ass thriller easily
one of my favorite thrillers of all time
and let me know if you've read it or if
you've seen the movie or anything like
that what you thought about it uh you
know just have a discussion about it
down in the comments and that will do it
for this tomes of terror i will see you
guys on the next one bye